[Music]
one of the core findings of our research
is that the political arguments that are
going to be effective for building a
bigger consensus in the u.s. is usually
an argument you haven't heard before
it's an argument that advocates for a
policy or a candidate in terms of the
values and beliefs of the people that
are being targeted for persuasion
we've tested this idea both ways we've
looked at whether liberal policy
positions do better when they're framed
in terms of conservative values and we
find that they do because they pull
greater support from conservatives and
sometimes moderates and then we've also
looked at whether conservative policy
positions perform better when they're
reframed in terms of liberal values and
again we find that they do so for
example if you were to reframe military
spending as consistent with equality of
opportunity and social justice making
the case for the military as an
institution where the poor and
minorities can achieve on a relatively
level playing field with other Americans
liberals will be more open to supporting
high levels of military spending after
they hear an argument like that
a few years ago we got really interested
in same-sex marriage attitudes and we're
interested in whether certain persuasive
techniques might be more effective for
building support for same-sex marriage
and so to explore this idea we ran an
experiment where we had people either
read a relatively conventional argument
for same-sex marriage that said that gay
marriage should be legal because of the
values of equality fairness gay people
should have the same rights as anybody
else
we compared the effects of that message
to a very different message that made
the case for same-sex marriage in terms
of the values of patriotism and group
loyalty and it said that gay people are
proud patriotic Americans they serve in
the military they contribute to our
economy and our society and for that
reason they deserve the same rights as
anybody else and what we found is that
that second message was significantly
more persuasive and it was especially
more persuasive with conservatives who
are normally reluctant to support
same-sex marriage especially at the time
we ran the study a few years ago but
then when they heard that argument in
terms of their own values more
conservative values around patriotism
group loyalty they said oh okay you know
like this is starting to speak to me and
some of them moved their their positions
on these issues
most recently we ran an experiment on
how to make the most persuasive appeal
you could for an economically
progressive political candidate and
specifically a presidential candidate so
we're interested in is there a way to
build greater levels of support for
economically progressive candidates and
the reason we were interested in this is
that if you look historically Americans
are actually quite supportive of federal
jobs programs minimum wage increases
paid family leave you know these sorts
of programs they pull very well in
America but Americans don't necessarily
vote for the candidates that would pass
those policies and so they don't get
passed at a high rate so we're very
interested in this puzzle so what we did
was we constructed an experiment where
we had a candidate who supported these
pretty popular policies and we either
had them talk about those policies in
terms of classically liberal values like
equality social justice protecting
vulnerable people or we had them talk
about them in what are often thought to
be more conservative values of respect
for tradition caring for family the
American Dream things like that and what
we found was that candidate that second
candidate that talked in terms of more
conservative values but about
economically progressive policies was
clearly the most popular candidate in
the experiment that we ran they gained
extra support from moderates and
conservatives alike and they you know
we're essentially in the study we're an
you know a shoo-in to win in an election
one thing that I think is really
attractive about moral reframing is it
offers an alternative to our you know
our only real technique that we think of
now as a way to build political
consensus which is compromise compromise
on policy move to the perceived middle
and and that's gonna be the way to pick
up 51% of voters or get something passed
and that's an unsatisfying tool if it's
the only tool you have and so it's
attractive I think to have another
alternative another way that you could
add voters add people to your base of
support besides just changing the policy
positions you advocate for especially if
you think those are the right policy
positions
you think about Barack Obama Ronald
Reagan you know these are people who
could Intuit what a given audience
needed you know and say that idea that a
majority of people we're gonna turn out
to be moved by and potentially say
different things to different groups you
know we often think that if you're
saying different things different groups
that that means you're a flip-flopper or
you're insincere
or you're being cynical or something
like that but I think that that's not
really a realistic critique in a
polarized society in a polarized society
where people value different things they
have incredibly diverse backgrounds
we're gonna have to be comfortable with
the fact that people are gonna have
different reasons for agreeing on things
that people are going to come to major
issues like inequality or climate change
and potentially take the same side on
them but for very different reasons and
if we're not comfortable with that we're
not going to get political consensus
I think that if we're gonna resolve all
these tensions productively it's gonna
mean that we somehow turn towards one
another and saw some humanity across
political lines like maybe the existing
strategies worked so badly that we wound
up saying you know what we're not gonna
do it that way the politics of division
they're not working they're hurting the
country as a whole
and they're not really even helping my
side get a critical mass to pass
anything and so I'm gonna try a
different way and then that's gonna be
us turning towards each other and seeing
a common humanity that we struggle to
see now
[Music]